en plein troisième vague épidémique les
soignants tire la sonnette d'alarmé
les syndicats appellent à manifester ce
jeudi et espère faire entendre leur
détresse au gouvernement malgré
l'engagement des personnels
la situation s'aggrave avec l'actuelle
pandémie qui entraîne un surcroît
d'activité à gérer en plus du suivi au
quotidien et classique des résidents et
patients dans ses établissements en
plein rebond épidémique
les soignants se disent en colère est
épuisée après de longs mois de lutte
contre le virus
il dénonce un manque de lits de lieu
d'accueil et de personnel mais également
une surcharge de travail en partie due à
la situation sanitaire actuelle
en cette journée nationale de
mobilisation du 21 janvier 2021
les syndicats du secteur social et
médico social privé et public de la
fédération de la santé et de l'action
sociale exige plus spécifiquement
l'égalité salariale entre tous les
agents et salariés d'un même
établissement quel que soit le secteur à
commencer par le versement des 183 euros
du ségur pour tous dans le secteur
social et médico social privé et public
un véritable plan emploi formation et de
reconnaissance des qualifications en
lien avec la campagne des 10 % 10 % de
temps de travail en moins 10 %
d'effectifs en plus 10 % d'augmentation
indiciaire et salariales 10% deux temps
de formation en plus le 12 janvier
dernier
les soignants étaient déjà descendus
dans la rue pour demander que la
revalorisation salariale de 183 euros
obtenus lors du ségur de la santé soit
accordée à tous les agents de l'hôpital
public
aujourd'hui on a aperçu avec cette crise
sanitaire qu'on avait
face à toutes les personnes qui sont
dans le froid qui sont dans
l'accompagnement une chance
extraordinaire d'avoir une forme de
conscience professionnelle collective
qui ont fait qu'on a tenu il n'est pas
acceptable qu'il n'y a pas la
reconnaissance salariale qui est là avec
ces derniers mois de plus en plus de
soignants ont décidé de claquer la porte
de l'hôpital public
preuve du malaise général qui règne au
sein du personnel de santé et ce alors
que le système hospitalier déjà sous
tension
la situation pourrait même s'aggraver
dans les prochaines semaines
en cas d'accélération de la propagation
du virus dans l'hexagone